pastor i know the answer to the question
i'm gonna ask you all right but to my
friend here
i want him to
hear it from you okay um if you were
baptized in another faith yes
and you come to the seventh-day
adventist
shouldn't you re-baptize
the strong
council is to get re-baptized now in
acts chapter 19
paul met 12 disciples who had been
baptized by john acts 19 1-7
john said unto paul said unto which
baptism were you baptized you said
john's baptism
john they said have you received the
holy ghost since you were baptized you
said we never heard about the holy ghost
what
he taught them then they were
re-baptized
when you realize you're coming to a
system of truth you were not familiar
with
that force is up to the spirit to
convict you your decisions will be let
me be re-baptized and start all over in
this new system of truth
the recommendation it's not a command
it's a recommendation be re-baptized
i was preaching somewhere
way over the seas
and uh
i made a call for baptism re-baptism 50
people came
my call was look you've been with god 40
years but you haven't grown
it's just a routine it's just you're
going through the motions
you need to start again
and 50 people came
and i took them aside to a room to speak
to them and a retired minister joined me
and he told us a very interesting story
in the middle of his ministry
he decided to be re-baptized because he
realized he hadn't grown he was passing
the church they were baptism the tithe
was fine but he himself was not really
growing so he went to the conference and
said mr president i want to be
re-baptized the person said what did you
do oh i didn't do anything
but i realized my spiritual life has
been just nothing
and i just can't go through the motions
i want to be re-baptized the president
said okay we'll re-baptize you at night
the pastor said no
baptize me in front of my church because
there are the members who need to make
the same step let them see
and he was re-baptized
i was preaching in another city
the associate pastor got re-baptized
i was in another city preaching the
pastor's wife and his son got
re-baptized because something about the
word revived them evangelism page 375
ella white writes when the soul is truly
reconverted let that soul be re-baptized
let him renew his covenant with god and
god will renew his covenant with him
reconversion must take place in the
churches
the strong council of the church is get
re-baptized
new beginning
all right who has the next hand yes my
brother yes